a man-made blackout is forcing tourists
to evacuate one of the East Coast's most
popular vacation spot at the height of
the summer season thousands of homes and
businesses in North Carolina's Outer
Banks have not had full power since
Thursday because of a construction
accident
authorities say the outage on two
islands could last up to two weeks
the Marco Morgan is in Nags Head North
Carolina with the local effort to
salvage the summer de Marco good morning
good morning right here is highway 12 it
is the main artery in the Outer Banks
and aside from ferry service and is the
only road that drivers can use to escape
the blackout residents are being allowed
back in but visitors they can't come
back until power is fully restored
construction crews are working around
the clock to get the power back on in
North Carolina's Outer Banks we have
been working very hard to make sure that
we can get our visitors back to the
island last year construction began on a
new bridge that will connect Hatteras
Island with the mainland on Thursday
workers accidentally damaged all three
underground transmission cables cutting
power to Hatteras and Ocracoke Islands
that mistake has forced an estimated
70,000 visitors to evacuate during the
peak summer season past couple of days
have been extremely frustrating charlie
horn fact owns the wreck a bar on
Hatteras Island
he says the blackout could cost him tens
of thousands of dollars in lost business
this is not a natural disaster this is
somebody's fault and I hope they step up
generators have been trucked in to help
provide limited power to year-round
homeowners who have been allowed to stay
our number one goal right now is is our
residence Robert Woodard its chair of
the Dare County Board of Commissioners
his first priority is caring for
business owners to keep the local
economy running with that being said we
can get our vistas in here so they can
continue to have a good season
who is the market on to solutions to
restore power one is to splice together
the damaged cables underground the other
is to build a transmission line that
would travel above ground the governor
is expected to tour the construction
site sometime later today Mac you know
what's interesting this is where I
learned to love the Atlantic Ocean but
an outage does tremendous damage to
everything we think of all the foods and
refrigerate everything else I mean and
it's a forewarning of what happens if
there's a cyber attack on our electoral
power which has been positive could
happen absolutely and at a minimum big
hit to the local economy at a time where
so many businesses this is their bread
and butter for the year like Christmas
forever be exactly